[Music]
all right welcome to the one o'clock
class you should be very excited at home
I'll let you calm down before I start
okay you've calmed down at home now
today the kids are going to be quieter
than usual because it's going to be on
the Internet this class you can see
yourself except you won't see yourself
you'll see me okay like maybe you can
hear yourself so this is round four of
the London chest classic which was being
shown behind me we turned it off and one
game is still going on you at home
the London chess classics went over for
two weeks but we're excited here
today is an ons birthday but not for you
at home okay so we're going to look at
two games that I played in the last
month okay my first opponent played
funny and since you all play funny I
thought you'd like this game okay my
opponent did everything wrong so he lost
so when I say he did everything wrong
are your ears burning because it's cold
in here so you know that would be good
right also get the cauliflower out of
your ears okay and take the pan in out
of your ears that keeps the alligators
away I can prove it who wants me to
prove it okay are there any alligators
in here no there you go right no no no
that's not that's a crocodile that's not
an alligator okay so my opponent played
very silly and if you play very silly
you might lose so you probably shouldn't
do that and this is a really good
example of playing silly
he decided that pawns don't go to
squares
okay now pawns can go one or two squares
on their first to move but maybe he
didn't know that his rating was about
1350 so they actually wrote several
volumes of books of stuff he didn't know
they're still writing it and by the way
the kids get nothing they had nothing
okay the one kids like what's a table
rasa okay so he played III and then he
played d3
then he played 92 so he's making sure he
goes as close as possible to himself
he's not moving out obviously the night
could go to f3 attacking my pawn and the
pawns could go to squares but he doesn't
do that see what he does
he plays what we call passively he
doesn't do anything he doesn't make any
threats he blocked both of his bishops
boo now his bishops can move ok terrible
what about my bishops my bishops get the
green light or in this case the green
arrow there's only one thing better than
blacks position does anybody know what
it is what's better than blacks position
you in correct
ooh that was a good answer that wasn't
as funny as my answer but it was close
the correct answer is the new Star Wars
movie that's better than my position why
I'm a grandmaster I saw things before
they even filmed ok I was in that movie
but they cut my scene as I wanted a
higher salary again see I'm a vegetarian
and I said I wanted celery they thought
I said salaries I got fired terrible
that's why I'm teaching this class ok
they said I was going rogue alright so
like one kid got their joke he actually
didn't get he's laughing anyway that
he's doing this because you think I got
it ok now when I play this position with
white which I have but don't tell
anybody
Shh I noticed that my bishops can't move
and I like to move my bishops so I do
something you've never heard of unless
you speak Italian who speaks Italian hey
nobody is lying in this class good job
ok and I feel ket all my bishops I play
g3 and b3 and I put my bishops here
because then my bishops moved out ok and
that's called the hippopotamus because
you are what you eat when I'm a
vegetarian
no no it's alright no Souris but nice
try
ok my opponent played 9g he played
Knight g3 that way his Bishop can get
out but that Knights not good there
because I could attack in then I'll take
it yes so I played h5 he didn't want me
to attack his knight so what did he do
to stop me he'd cry and then what did he
do
let's call on a small child Emily that's
correct
age 4 now I can't play h5 now they tell
you something that's too hard for you
but it's way too hard for the people at
home they're going to start crying ok
then
like the people watching at home their
mom's going to write me a letter you
made my son cry when he was watching the
chess video and I'm going to write back
and say well your son's 43 so that's too
bad
ok now in this position I'm controlling
this square see you agree right and he's
controlling this square but he can't put
anything on this square he can't do
anything but I can put my knight here I
can put my bishop there I'm the best
I wonder which piece I put there my
nitre my bishop let me think about that
which one didn't move yet but I try to
move everything once then I move
something else
some people they move this same piece
every move then all of their pieces are
on the back rank and then I beat them ok
so I move my bishop there I wonder what
my bishops attacking I think it's
attacking his knight
[Music]
it's attacking my queen the white queen
did he give up his queen and then resign
no so what did he do to prevent me from
- I know what he did he took my bishop
now then I could take his queen and he
would cry so what did he do you he moved
f2 to f3 he could do that but I have a
rule for my advanced students never play
f3 ok f3 is a good move but he didn't do
that
he blocked with his Bishop and I played
Queen d7 I protected my Bishop again Wow
my bishops protected a lot now these
pawns didn't move and this pawn didn't
move so am I going to castle on the
Queen side or the Kings side I'm going
to castle on the Queen side because I'm
ready to castle but I'm not ready to
castle here there's a bishop in the way
and when I Castle I leave all the pawns
in front of my king so my king is safe
ok so he played a3 if you ask me why I'm
going to say I don't know okay and then
I canceled so notice every move I make
every breath I take I move a different
piece every move that way all of my
pieces moved ok
also I move forward if I keep moving
forward he'll have to move backward and
then I'll be off the board and then I'll
win he never moves forward everything he
has is really is next to his king he's
not attacking any of my pieces he's
doing nothing ok
he played b4 no my King and I played
Bishop d6 now I moved all of my minor
pieces and I castled do I ever teach you
to do that that's all I ever teach you
ok and he played efore he moved the same
pawn twice and he didn't move his bishop
yet
now if you're going to stare at this
rook the whole lesson you're going to
notice it doesn't move and then I won
yay okay I took his pawn did he take
back or he let me went upon for free now
he took back and then I cried okay and
then I took his knight and he took my
knight okay now let's see let me think
about this should you play on the side
or the center yeah the center I wonder
where the center is oh there it is
that's the center right okay so I played
Knight to d4 that's the center I wonder
what my Knights attacking dish if I have
a knight attacking the bishop and I have
a bishop attacking the bishop all right
now a lot of kids in the class so I'm
attacking the pawn is that a good move
that's a risky move because you'll take
my knight but this is not a risky move
because I'll win so he played f3 as
suggested before what's the f3 pawn
attacking the bishop did I leave my
bishop there and lose my bishop no I
retreated like a Frenchman Bishop e6 Wow
my opponent makes lots of pawn moves and
my opponent has a lot of pieces on the
back row is that what I teach
no but he's playing me so that's okay
if he was my student I would be mad but
he's my opponent then I figure I'll win
you with some crazy comment
hey that was pretty crazy thank you good
job yeah all right the partial credit
okay
now he played Bishop b2 and I played
Bishop e7 now he made the losing move
when is it correct to make the losing
move when I'll accept chewy answers you
I will accept that answer
you never that's one answer but there's
a better answer a much funnier one a
bathrooms over there what's your answer
what is it correct to make the losing
move the answer is when you're playing
me yes because then I win
okay
partial credit okay now I'm attacking
his pawn is he defending his pawn how
about yes
what's defending his pawn the rook on h1
so should I take his pawn and lose my
bishop no but he left me because he's a
nice guy he did what's called a Ken West
okay Ken West is a grandmaster who comes
to the club a lot and he told me once
you know been sometimes my opponent
makes a threat and then I stop it and
then I forget about it then the next
move I let him do it again
he told me that's his problem so in this
position I'm attacking his pawn but he's
defending it so he stopped defending it
he played castles so I said oh boy a
free pawn yay so that was good if you
wanted to castle he could have protected
his pawn again and then castled or he
could have not cancelled okay so I'm a
pawn ahead and he attacked my knight did
I give my knight away for nothing
no did I move my knight where he could
take it now
I played Knight f5 and I have a threat
that's a 2 o'clock class threat for 1
o'clock this is really hard let me show
how hard it is wow that was hard
I better get something to drink hmm got
a long island up that iced tea okay so
the knight on f5 is threatening to fork
his Queen and rook who can find it you
yeah night where somewhere whatever that
square is all right tell me is the
square green or red which one red night
to the red square okay if I do that my
Knights attacking his Queen and his rock
that's called a fork did he let me do
that actually if you knew my opponent
it'd be 5050 but he didn't let me do it
he played Queen d2 did I still go here
no because he would take my knight and I
would cry so I played Queen e7 so my
queen and Bishop are defending each
other and my rook is opposite his queen
maybe one day my rook will take his
queen maybe like on a Tuesday right okay
so he moved his Queen away because he
was scared let's see I moved this and
this and this this and this I wonder
what piece I didn't move yet Oh
so I played rookie six and that's called
a rook lift
unless you're Jennifer Shahade II that
is called a Rover I move my rook up and
over Rover and then when my rook goes
here I'm going to show his king who the
boss is the answer Tony Danza no I'm
just kidding
you with some great comment
yeah yeah that's correct
let's go back even though I saw never
going back if I take their pawn is my
rook safe what would what would Dustin
Hoffman say what would Laurence Olivier
say what he would say is it safe a
Dustin Hoffman wouldn't know what to say
because he's just a marathon runner he's
not a spy he doesn't know right good all
right so if I take his pawn he'll take
my rock although knowing this guy I
might have got away with it okay so I
played in Rupp cage six did he take my
rook for free it isn't for free because
I would take his queen I have a couple
ways to do it
he played see for what see for what even
this class knows that Wow
I was I was I was expecting nothing yeah
c4 is explosive so I gave up because he
played c4
that's why I'm a grandmaster I'm not a
grandmaster at chess I'm a grandmaster
of giving up that's why I'm getting
married in two weeks
yay yeah it's true thank you thank you
no nothing did you guys bring your
wedding gifts you guys at home can mail
a check no no check is too large so you
know raise it up okay what you that's
correct also if I lost will I be showing
you that game terrible okay so I played
9 to d4
remember when he attacked my knight and
then I moved it away remember that now
his pawns not there anymore so I put my
knight back on the center I wonder what
I'm threatening what's black threatening
hold on I'm fending something Oh the
bishop and then and then it Forks his
king and queen and if you don't like
that you could fork the Queen and Rock
so that's what we call a good night
Knights of the center ok
he took my knight and I took his bishop
wow look at all of my pieces out doing
stuff and look at all of his pieces
hiding on the back row also this rogue
didn't move yet in fact it never moves
wait a minute that's a great Bishop it
has lots of places to go to just just
kidding that's the worst bishop ever my
bishop has a thousand places to go to I
mean ten thousand again my dish of some
maniac it has ten thousand places to go
to would you get that one alright no
talking his Bishop boo okay so he
attacked my bishop now I have a question
should you leave pawns in front of your
king or should you get all the pawns
away from your king yeah if the pawns
are infront of your king nobody is going
to get you okay so when the president
has security guards are they a thousand
miles away are they standing next to him
yeah so my security guards are next to
my king and he was like oh how about you
go on vacation we I don't need you there
go here okay just move away from me so
my opponent can check meet me all right
now most of you would move your bishop
away because your bishops attacked and
the rest of you would give up your
bishop because you didn't see 96 bishop
okay
I did something you've never heard of
it's called a pin that was more complain
than I expected no no no I wasn't
talking to you
I was talking to people at home they
never heard of a pin okay they're like I
have a pin right here
oh I stabbed myself okay so this pawn is
in front of his King if I put a rook or
a queen there he can't move his pawn BAM
now most of you would take the bishop
but the computer won't let me look at
the computer not letting me because then
he'd be in check that's called a pin so
I'm attacking this pawn how many times
how many times is black attacking the
pawn more than one very good how about a
more accurate answer I also accept PI
not the number pi but free PI you two
one two everybody buckle their shoe okay
now he's defending it once two is more
than one so if it's my move I can start
taking things so he protected his pawn
king h2 and I did something you've never
done and will never do a combination
okay I sacrificed my bishop and then
when he took it and I put him in check
he started crying I sacrificed my bishop
did he take with the King or the night
the night he takes with a king that
would be illegal to boo the night
now I played the meanest check ever and
he was like oh that's not good what's
the winning move for black totally
crushing White's open King you in the
corner
you change your mind all right you with
the right answer you're 2/3 correct it
does because that's the move that I made
it can't be checked me there is no
checkmate all right you right now Rick
aged four also should win but Queen age
four wins more and I mean now he's in
check and I'm attacking this night a lot
okay so this position so good for black
if you were playing the world champion
you might win in fact some of you might
win in two moves and some of you the
world's champion would resign that's how
bad whites position is my opponent gave
up let's pretend he didn't give up he
would move his king right and I would go
check notice how my rook and queen are
protecting each other what's that called
that's not checkmate yet when you're
Rick and Queen are protecting each other
what do we call that you powerful is
right what what this is the one o'clock
class so we'll be here for a while yes
you're cheating you come from the two
o'clock class you're refugee see the two
o'clock class okay that's called a
battery it's also called check it's also
called powerful all of your answers were
right
how many legal moves does white have how
many possible moves what's the only move
what can white do resigns the best to
move but what's the possible move white
can make you with the right answer
[Music]
I'm a I'm a changed my answer in a
second
well he can't go King to g3 because my
rook is defending it so the computer
won't let me you in correct you what
what what
he can't because his king is in check by
my queen he has to get out of check did
you ever watch the low talker episode on
Seinfeld because you could do that also
what alright you with the right answer
you have the right answer yeah
movies came to h1 because that's the
only move now here's a question that
nobody can answer because it's too hard
how many checkmates does black have even
been Simon can't answer that
there's too many answers if you close
your eyes and make a legal move it might
be checkmate
that's how many checkmates there are ok
who said for I think four is right
okay so Queen z2 is checkmate Queen age
threes checkmate Queen age fours
checkmate and rook age fours checkmate
I think that's it yeah so because every
move is checkmate my opponent gave up
let's look at the piece activity all his
pieces on the back row and his bishop
can't move all my pieces fantastic
nobody around my king my Kings really
safe so my king is safe his King is
unsafe all my pieces went forward all
his pieces stayed home so I won okay
then what did he do cry right yeah and
then I gave him a copy of my book cry
like a Grand Master okay then he gave a
copy of his book cry like a class-d
player alright that's been Simon's
favorite book okay now the last game of
the day was played was the played
yesterday let's see now it was played
last week boo now there's somebody who
works at the club if you can call it
working and his name is Danny Machuca
Danny Machuca gets chess lessons every
day sometimes for me sometimes from
other grandmasters has it affected his
rating no okay because it goes in here
and out there right I'm like do this and
he's like ah hahaha then the next thing
he's like what okay so alright now this
is the most amazing game in chess
history I'm going to tell you why when I
play Danny Machuca he always has white
he's like I want white he's like a
little kid when I want white okay and
this game I had white so I was like well
what's
happening why do I have Wyatt so I've
never had white against him I've played
him for a year he's like yeah I want to
have black now and I was like I you
dandy Machuca it turned out we watched
the movie invasion of the Body Snatchers
and he kept doing this but I didn't
suspect anything
right okay so because I had white I was
very confused because I've never had
white against him so I blundered every
move I played so badly
it took me 19 moves to checkmate him
yeah so I so I cried for a day I'd take
a day off work okay they told me to take
two it should be so long to beat him
they felt bad for me at work okay so we
played the slob defense which is very
common and he played the a sick slob
because he played a 6c and I played a
four and I had this position once before
my opponent went here and we decided to
play checkers instead yet none of
nothing okay he played Bishop f5 now
let's go back let's go back to the
beginning you see all these pawns that
are in red and you see all these pawns
that are in green because it's like
Christmas time I'm going to tell you a
shocking story they're all protected so
this rook protects this pawn this Bishop
protects this pawn this consent so on
okay and when we played our game and he
moved out his bishop he unprotected one
of his pawns this one that was protected
and now it's an eye I wish I could take
it how could I attack his pawn hold on
let me think about it
man how could I take that pawn you
I could do that but I could put
something on b3 right now your way works
but takes two moves I did in one move
bathrooms over there yeah
did I point this way if somebody over
there said me what no I was I was
calling on Bensimon no I wasn't okay
Queen b3 is correct I want to take his
pawn yummy yummy
but he was mean he defended his pawn he
defended in a funny way not funny to you
here the one o'clock class but funny to
like Bensimon rook a7 actually the
points of a6
now your rook can defend your point okay
I developed my piece remember what I
said last game I move a different piece
every move
I still do okay and he played pawn takes
pawn attacking my queen I took back now
where did he move his bishop hmm
nowhere but he wanted to move his bishop
so he played a six now his Bishop has a
lot of squares okay I played efore
attacking his bishop if he takes with a
knight then I take his Queen that's
because his knight is pinned so he moved
his Bishop and now I made the winning
move now I say this in chess classes all
the time when you're pinning your
opponent's piece you want to attack it
with another piece because it's pinned
so I'm pinning his knight to his queen
that means if his knight moves I take
his Queen how can i attack his knight
again you Frank
with the right answer
right how old are you Frank you're 5
you're already 5 when did you turn five
a long time ago this month solid happy
birthday November 6th that's 2 months
after my birthday
what yeah but it was within a month see
he turned five in November you guys
turned five like at least a week or two
ago all right
so Frank said II five now I'm attacking
his night I'm attacking his night if his
night moves away I take his queen he
attacks my bishop and I have a funny
story in this position he was thinking
hmm if my opponent attacks my knight I'm
going to attack their bishop then I'm
going to attack their Bishop again but
when you play Bishop g6 he blocked his
pawn right but he didn't realize that
till afterwards it was very funny so
when you attacked my bishop when I went
here he was intending on going here then
he saw that he can't do that he was like
ah okay so now he's losing a knight and
he should lose the game but he was
playing me so he had a chance so he
played Queen b6 attacking my pawn and I
was like what's worth more an either
upon a knight so I took the night and he
took my pawn now I hallucinate 'add okay
don't do that
I said he if I play rook be one he'll
take with his Bishop so that's not good
if I play rook a to and he checks me and
I blocked the check then I'm losing my
queen I forgot my bishop is protecting
my queen so that's just a queen trade
and I forgot my queen was protected so
if I had played rook a to I would just
be up a knight
and he thought I would play rook a to
but I didn't see my Queen was defended
by my bishop so I played a terrible move
rook do you want
and and he pinned my knight Bishop b4 ah
so my Knights attacked twice and I can't
defend it if I defend with the rook then
he takes my rook so that didn't work too
well if I defend this way he also takes
my rook so I'm going to lose my knight
luckily I took his knight already okay
so I took his pawn he checked me you see
I'm in check how did I get out of check
what did I do
is it checkmate or can I get out of
check how did I get out
Knight to d2 right okay now his rooks
attacked so he moved it okay now Queen
c5 is winning but I played a bad move
Bishop d3 and he did something you never
heard of called removing the defender
okay and I told you this story before
you want to rob a bank and then you're
like oh it's Sunday I guess I'll go to
kids class okay and you go to the bank
and you're all ready to rob the bank but
there's a security guard there so you go
home and cry what you should have done
is brought a doughnut with you then you
put the doughnut outside the security
guard goes and gets it then you rob the
bank okay so this is the security guard
my queen if he takes my bishop I'll take
with the Queen right so he made my Queen
move away he played b5 and wherever I
move my queen my bishops not defended
but I can attack his rook and I did now
the game should end in a draw if he
plays correctly did he play correctly
does he ever play correctly no good job
if only daddy was here okay watch how
it's a draw it's the kind of draw you
guys like it's where you move back and
forth forever then you all start
laughing so he could take my bishop some
of you think this is check me but his
rook would take my queen
that would be bad so I can take his rook
now he takes my night with check is that
checkmate
now I take his bishop and now he checks
me forever check check check
if you don't like that you can check on
a one also and and that's called
perpetual check the same position
occurred three million times and that's
a draw okay so he could have drawn
against me and his readings 1800 in my
range twenty five seventy so he would
have liked that he would have been like
I drew a grandmaster that's all you had
to do but he played for the wind also
known as playing for the loss he played
Bishop takes d4 and actually that move
wins for black except that it loses I
have one move there wins and all my
other moves lose he didn't see the move
that wins so he thought he was winning
he was like old boy I'm attacking Ben's
Queen I'm defending my rook I'm
attacking his Bishop I'm up a pawn he
was really happy then I made the move
that he didn't see Queen d6 Queen d6
threatens checkmate which he didn't see
and threatens Queen takes Knight check
winning both of his rooks which he did
see but if he plays 97 which stops both
threats then I play checkmate because my
bishop defends my queen so in this
position the computer which gives a
point evaluation like +1 is a pawn +5 is
a rook it says I'm plus 24 so the
computer likes my position now here the
computer says it's a draw here it says
whites up 24 so his last move wasn't
good ok now Danny saw Queen takes Knight
check but he didn't see Queens e8 main
so he defended his night with his Bishop
via an x-ray if I take his Knight he
takes my queen if I take his bishop he
takes my queen
so he thought he was winning so he's
like hey I'm still winning and then I
played me then he's not winning right
now just like in the previous games I
move all my pieces and he keeps his
knight here because that's safe there
again and because I moved my bishop out
it was protecting my queen when the
bishop and queen protect each other
that's called a you said it before so
I'm calling on you a battery okay so and
also he has a battery okay and I like to
put pepper on my food
but he likes to put salt so he had a
salt and battery right none of the kids
got it none of them zero and like half
their parents okay the other half were
at Starbucks yeah and they're like I
would like assault and battery please
and they're like this is Starbucks okay
but it's Christmas time so they get in
line so when I was at my chess house my
chess house I ordered on my phone
Starbucks and then I was like lalala
that's a Christmas season then I walked
over to Starbucks and there were five
billion people in line more than half
the earth and my drink was sitting I got
my drink and I left everybody's like
what how do you do that and they said
did you order from your phone and I said
I'm a grandmaster my drinks was waiting
here and they're like oh okay
and what did I say to the Starbucks
people after I grab my drink I said
class is dismissed
[Music]